[Music]
the 2018 Sakharov Prize for freedom of
thought has been awarded to oleg sentsov
the ukrainian filmmaker and political
prisoner in russia
his work has earned praise at
International Film Festival's sense of
delayed work on a second film to protest
Russia's annexation of Crimea in 2015 a
Russian Court sentenced him to 20 years
in prison on charges of plotting
terrorist acts he is incarcerated in a
remote penal colony in the Arctic Circle
Ivana is Direction Apache diet they are
very honest on IG its design is Turkish
tonne of widgets some know whether two
three years ago Charlie Webb shake it
says Putin scheduled field in 2018 he
started a hunger strike to draw
attention to the plight of political
prisoners in Russia he was forced to end
it after a hundred and forty five days
because of serious ill health allegory
signals to avoid burning Nebraska stop
our producers today I hope a lot of kir
mere star bully a groom coverage of
crazy a political journalist urge that
they evoke a drastic by be edible the
Parliament is calling for the immediate
release of oleg sentsov who has become a
symbol for the liberation of all
political prisoners in russia no cedis
or e0 cristo parlamento sara same prey
of Ostrow yeah
[Music]